I can tell you that your colleagues have
left you some Falco workloads on the cluster.
So we have file side QI?
Yep. If you wanna access the Falco side
QI, I'm happy to open it in a
terminal browser on the site just so the
audience can follow along. I mean, right now,
doesn't the kind of thing's broken. So yeah.
So
Okay.
To connect to the database. To connect to
database. Password notification. That
there's also an image here in the page.
You can can we open it with the
browser? Where is the chat?
Okay.
Looks looks like we're looks like we're upset.
Should we go take a look what the
sidekick is
telling us? If if tell if we get
any hint
from Yeah. Maybe any any fault code,
of all. Maybe it's captured something.
We are an an exec into a board.
The DB program was spawned,
and Bash history was deleted.
A naughty person has been on one of
these pods, I think. Schedule cron jobs.
Keep scrolling.
Three times.
Delete or in a mystery.
Attach
or exec import. Definitely, somebody has gone
into one of these pod. Which one is
it? Yeah. And there is a an alternate
user
in the database.
Mhmm.
It's Postgres. Right? There's also the password in
the altar command.
It's like So Mhmm. Not today. So the
so somebody
somebody
went
somebody somebody went into the Postgres
pod and manually changed the password. Is that
what they is that that what they did?
It's very cool that Falco gives you visibility
into
these arbitrary random
commands within a pod. That's pretty sweet.
Here we go. Here, the Postgres pod is
running engine x latest.
Oh,
wrong image, but the Falco UI also said
something.
Containers image, Postgres one three Alpine.
So we have a meeting in webhook somewhere.
Those are nasty. I would maybe get rid
of that. I mean, your falco UI here
shows you that the web hook, QDNS,
is modifying
all all container images to be engine x
latest. So I did it. I did it.
I can delete, man, right now.
That's no kit. Yeah. Music and webhooks are
are pretty opaque. You don't know what they
do. You just know the permissions they have.
So we
we do have v one. So, currently, our
application is working.
Oh, look at that.
So now you have to upgrade it to
v two.
Just do a sysdig with the
event dot type equal exec v,
and we're seeing and and we can see
the executions
in the cluster.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly.
There's some kind of hidden
process probably somewhere.
Here,
there's a process
There's a process code, definitely not.
Yeah. That looks like question. Yeah.
Why do you say it?
Or
now that we need What is definitely not?
What is definitely not? What is that?
It used to be running date and sleep,
and
those are interesting. What if we just kill
that process? We have the paid from
Sysdig. Right? Try try just to do a
Sysdig filter with the definitely,
prog name prog prod dot name
contains
Definitely.
Maybe
let's try.
But, again, I don't know when the damn
thing starts, but let's try.
And before the filter, do the HP
proc dot p name.
Can you scroll up in
the meantime?
Because there there is the that clone.
The clone should contain the parent too. Yeah.
P t system d.
It's system d. Arguments
the arguments is bar catch. Definitely not. So
this is run by system d? Just kill
kill dash nine system d.
Yeah. Kevin,
that's a good way to do it. I
killed the p I d one. Okay.
Yeah. Exactly.
Guys, have you have you seen the Falco
UI service there?
Do you see that?
I would like to check the service Falco
UI, System CTL cat
Falco UI serve
Good call.
There you are,
Definitely not. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
Not
today.
So this That looks nice. Lips forever,
checks to see if the pod is
old, and resets the password on Postgres. Good
catch, Vicente.
You have to dance.
Woah.